so what you're seeing here is a frenzy
around Bola Ahmad tanubu one of the main
contenders in this presidential race
he's known as The Godfather of Lagos
this is his estate he was the governor
of Lagos and this is where 7.1 million
people have signed up to vote so tanubu
here to vote today in his home state The
Godfather of Lagos the frenzy around him
is typical he's a very influential man
here he is up against the main
opposition Party's candidate atiku
abubakar a former vice president now
tinubu is projected to win the state
majority candidates need two-thirds of
the state vote that's 24 out of 36
states to win this election and he is
known to invest in Grassroots
politicians they are Governors all over
the country that owe to nubu for their
seat so he could very well win this race
but if there is a wild card there is
Peter obi's 61 year old former Banker
now he has galvanized young people here
much the tinubu chagran and he is
unlikely to get the majority of the
state vote but he could very well split
the popular vote enough so that saluku
doesn't get the 50 needed which could
drive this election to an unprecedented
runoff the first in the country's
political history